for the crime of making this observation
Hassan the God he's the young guy from
The Young Turks I think he's chenk
euger's nephew
I did a show with him once it was on one
of the Fox shows with him one time uh he
said that I'm I'm Desiring violence
I pointed out
the Republican view on this which is
that the Democrats rigged the elections
and I said the longer it takes to tally
the votes the less you should believe
the result he Hassan says pretty wild
that the Republican party is
collectively gearing up Their audience
to lose their minds after they did
everything to make sure Mal and ballot
results come in later than same-day
votes I don't even think Dems will win
but it's certain that they want violence
where
in what insane world could you possibly
interpret what I said
as calling for violence
I said the longer it takes to tally the
votes the less you should believe the
result where it show me the violence
take me out of it for a second
where have you ever seen ever the
Republicans committing violence over an
election
well we saw it on January 6th when the
Republicans murdered all those police
officers and know that none of that
happened none of that happened the only
person who was killed in political
violence on January 6th was a trump
supporter
killed by a trigger-happy cop
okay
now where else have we seen political
violence have we seen any political
violence in recent years
oh yeah when that lib tried to murder
Justice Kavanaugh and oh yeah yesterday
when I lived through a beer can at Ted
Cruz's head and oh yeah when the
Democrats burned the country down for
like eight months during the BLM and
antifa riots killing dozens of people
and burning businesses and setting
courthouses on fire yeah I guess we saw
it then didn't we
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah on
setting churches on fire on and on and
on
statistically 100 of political violence
in the U.S comes from the Democrats
statistically zero percent of it ever
comes from the Republicans
but
the Democrats believe that they're
justified in political violence because
they're fighting the evil fascist nazi
racist threat to our democracy namely
every Republican in the country
and they believe that Republicans are
are illegitimate citizens and they have
no right to do anything
they believe that the very the continued
existence of Republicans is inflicting
violence in the country that is what the
president has said
so it's it is absurd but my observation
Remains the Same the loser is going to
deny the election
that's just a fact
and and there could be violence Hassan
is right in that there could be violence
it will not come from the right
we don't have enough power for it we
don't have the inclination for it we do
have a view of the world that includes
objective morality we just don't want to
do it for all the rights talk of well
we've got our guns we got our Second
Amendment the right is not interested in
political violence the left is the left
exercises political violence constantly
and if they lose you'll probably see
more of it
and you are already seeing him a little
bit because my friend Ted Cruz actually
was he was pretty sprightly up there he
was on a campaign vehicle going through
the streets some guy it wasn't even a
beer can he threw it was a white claw
cam which is very funny I love white
claws but it's kind of a girly drink to
throw at somebody uh they went
Senator Cruz was able to fend off the
can I think the guy got arrested and
then and then Ted tweeted out and said
uh thank goodness that guy has a noodle
for an arm because it didn't hurt too
bad but you were already seeing the
violence and it ain't coming from the
right there was a big announcement last
night
I get a text from Jeremy says turn on
the Trump rally
so why
it's Trump there's rumors he might
announce that he's running for president
turn on the Trump rally it's a rally in
Ohio for JD Vance very important race as
goes Ohio so goes the nation
Trump's out there campaigning until the
last minute
but he was teasing all night you heard
the media
showing up is he going to announce that
he's running in 2024
and I thought instantly no he's not
a lot of people thought he would
Trump supporters thought he would a lot
of people who hate Trump thought that he
would
I did not think that he would it doesn't
look good enough it's not enough about
him the Optics weren't great some people
said well his family's there the whole
family was not there his wife I don't
think was there Baron I don't think was
there so it just I never bought it I
suspected from the beginning that it was
a media troll so that Trump could get
all the news networks to turn on the
cameras for his rally and then he would
just read the Litany of candidates that
he was endorsing in the race and then
he made this announcement I would say in
the strongest way it's a country-saving
election
specifically including
the election of all the people that I'm
going to name
I'm going to be making
a very big announcement on Tuesday
November 15th at Mar-A-Lago in Palm
Beach Florida
we want nothing to detract from the
importance of tomorrow
they want nothing to detract from the
importance of Tomorrow Trump and the
whole team so is a troll it was a troll
from the beginning which is really great
stuff absolutely adore it
uh and then Trump comes out and he says
but
that announcement that you're waiting
for I am going to make it next Tuesday
so Trump is going to run
almost certainly
and I don't know am I the last
conservative pundit in America who
doesn't hate Trump
maybe that's too strong am I the last
conservative pundit in America who
wouldn't be upset if Trump runs again
I like Trump
Trump was the greatest conservative
president in my lifetime Trump posed a
legitimate I think a real serious threat
to the system from the system of
absolutely
desiccated corrupt decadent liberal
establishment nonsense
he posed a threat in a way that no
Republican in my lifetime has and are
there other potentially good candidates
on the right sure and they'll duke it
out in a primary process but I'm just
not willing to throw Trump aside the man
is still very energetic the man is
unique in American politics he is a
world historic figure he is a sort of
hegelian character okay it is all about
him some people say well why is Trump
making it all about him one he didn't
make it all about him last night he
actually did wait until after the
election and endorsed his candidates but
two
it is all about him he is an American
original one of a kind and so I'm not
willing to say oh Trump
oh he's too old oh he's too his tweets
are too mean oh whatever no I like him I
still like the guy
I will not be upset if he runs I hope
that whatever primary campaign takes
place does not
destroy other strong good Republicans
there's a lot of them out there
everyone's talking about Ron DeSantis
but there's others as well I hope that
it's a good strong robust primary we get
the best candidate but I don't know the
arguments against Trump to me fall flat
well Trump is so bruised and bloodied
right you don't think they're going to
do that to whoever the nominee is
in fact in some ways they've they've
thrown the kitchen sink at trump it
hasn't stuck so hey that's actually a
Mark I think in his favor
well Trump is too old yeah okay we won
every every conservative's last favorite
Republican president
was the oldest president in American
history so I don't think that and now we
just liked old people so okay that's the
way it goes uh
he got Roe v Wade overruled he built a
fair portion of the wall he had the best
foreign policy ever in my lifetime uh he
uh brought peace to the Middle East for
goodness sakes
he got tough on trade he reordered
Republicans economic priorities into a
much more sane sort of way he I don't
know I just I'm not saying he's the best
candidate necessarily for 2024. I
haven't really looked at the 2024 race
all that closely yet because we're
focused on the midterms but
I'm not willing to throw the guy out I
just really like him I still like the
guy okay all right and that's that I
make no apologies for it
though he was rushing things a little
bit last night he's right you know it's
early it's 2022 why are we talking about
2024. you know the rest of the show
continues now
we got a great pollster on to tell us
what to look for tonight if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]